a dos semanas de la reapertura total de
inglaterra el primer ministro boris
johnson dijo palabras más palabras menos
que se debe aprender a vivir con el
virus porque la pandemia no se ha
acabado aseguro que es el momento
oportuno porque la vacunación la más
eficaz de toda europa está dando sus
resultados se han reducido notablemente
el número de muertes y de
hospitalizaciones estamos en verano y
los niños no están en las escuelas por
ello a partir del próximo 19 de julio ya
no será obligatorio el uso de
mascarillas pero esta será una decisión
voluntaria además se reducirán también
el número de semanas la brecha para la
segunda dosis de vacunación de 12 a 8
semanas todos los sectores de la
economía volverán a abrir incluidos los
clubes nocturnos se acaba la regla de un
metro de distanciamiento social y ya no
será obligatorio trabajar desde la casa
en la medida de lo posible
también boris johnson advirtió que
posiblemente aumentarán los contagios
diarios en 50.000 casos y así también
número de muertes con esta reapertura
los científicos y los expertos han
criticado esta medida de reapertura que
se da en medio de un pico de contagios
de kobe de 19 y también que se elimine
la regla de uso de tapabocas
especialmente en lugares cerrados